さあ一度きれいにしました現状このディファインプロップスのところに黄色い波線で警告が出ているんですね
これ何でかっていうと実はビュージェイスはプロップスに対してバリデーションつまり正しく予期したデータが渡されているかを検証する機能を持っているんですね
でそれを書いていないので今警告が出てしまっていますので今回と次のレクチャーで
そのバリデーションについて詳しく説明したいと思います
でじゃあバリデーションどうするかっていうとここの引数の部分を配列じゃなくてオブジェクトにするんですね
でそのキーにプロップスの名前を入れます
でその値にいろんな検証するときのルールを入れることができまして
例えばデータの型を直接こんな風に先頭大文字でナンバーのように指定することができます
こうした場合はナンバー型つまり数字以外のデータをこの風に渡してしまうと
開発中の場合はコンソールでこんな風に警告をナンバー型のところにストリング文字列が入ってますよという風に出してくれるようになります
またここのですねナンバーと直接書いた値のところにオブジェクトを入れることができまして
そこにタイプというキーを置いてでナンバーと指定しても同じように設定することができます
でもしこれオブジェクトにした場合は他にもいろんな設定を書くことができまして
例えばRequiredをTrueとすると必ずWhoのプロップスを親で指定する必要があるという風になります
なのでもしWhoというプロップスを置かなければこれも同じように警告が出るようになります
また他にもデフォルトという設定もすることができまして
これはもし何もプロップスが設定されていなかった時に代わりに使うデフォルトの値を設定することができます
なのでRequiredだとデフォルトは共存して一緒に使うということはないですね
必ず必要なんだったらデフォルトの値は使われないですし
逆にデフォルトの値が使われるのであればRequiredはFalseになっている必要があります
Requiredは何も設定していなければFalseになりますので
こんな風にデフォルト100として何も設定していなければ
ちゃんとですねデフォルトの値の100が使われているのがわかると思います
ちなみにデフォルトプロパティのデフォルトの値
ちょっとややこしいんですけれどもつまり何も設定していなかった時ですね
この時は今親でも設定されていないという状況では
このFはUndefinedになります
でもUndefinedはちょっと正しく表示されないんですけれども
例えばFuイコールイコールイコールUndefinedとすると
Toolと出ることからデフォルトのデフォルトの値はUndefinedなんだと
こういうことがわかると思います
また親の子でプロプスを指定する時に明示的にUndefinedを指定した場合
この時にもしデフォルトの設定が書かれてあれば
これはこのデフォルトの値が使われます
なのでちょっとこちら消してみてみるとこんな風に100と出るわけですね
なのでデフォルトの値はそのプロプスが何も指定されていない時
もしくはUndefinedと指定されている時に使われるということです
これがざっくりのプロプスのバリデーションになります
こういう設定にしておくことでプロジェクトが大きくなったりとかして
間違えてプロプスに違うデータの種類を入れてしまったりとか
もしくはそもそも指定し忘れたりとかした時も
すぐに警告で教えてくれたりしますので
早期発見ができて非常に便利な機能になります
リンターもタイプを指定していなければ
こんな風にタイプはなるべく付けるようにしましょうという風な傾向を出してくれますし
逆にデフォルトもしくはリクワイヤードのどっちかがないと
それもこんな風になるべくどっちか付けましょうねという警告を出してくれますので
プロプスを定義する時はなるべくこんな風に詳細に
その内容まで指定するようにしてください
このバリデーションですね
もう少し詳細な説明をすることもできまして
ちょっと長くなりますので
次のレクチャーでもう少し深掘って説明したいと思います
ご視聴ありがとうございました